now on good day removing a local
official accused of murder from his
position the latest efforts by Clark
County
plus paying less for prescription
medication the announcement made by
Governor sisalak to save you some money
and interest rates going up once again
what you should do to protect your
Investments Good Day Las Vegas starts
right now
now
this is good day Las Vegas live local
now six o'clock Thursday morning Don is
off this morning you got us three and
it's a beautiful day out to have sherry
oh the warnings have been really nice
they really have they've already started
to feel a little bit like Windows up
yeah but this is really the last
Afternoon Of Summer okay last morning
last Afternoon Of Summer and then we'll
roll into Fall by this evening so I'm
summer you guys are you guys are fall
we're just kind of eventually we're
evolving that's what we are it's
beautiful outside happy Thursday
everybody ready for the weekend things
are going to change a little bit again
as we get into the weekend but man what
a gorgeous shot looking through the High
Roller off to the east side of the
valley and we see fewer clouds out there
this morning and then we have most days
that's because a lot of that rain that's
been plaguing Arizona has been moving up
now into Colorado and Utah and away from
the Four Corners region still a little
bit left this morning but not nearly as
much as they've had 70 to humidity 26
percent we're staying dry 35 is the dew
point and we're a few degrees cooler
this morning than we were yesterday
Sunrise 6 29 637 is the sunset so we're
just about at equal day and equal night
because of the tilts of the Earth's axis
uh it's not perfectly to the minute but
it's oh so close 70 is a good average 10
we're clear it's a little cooler this
morning kids feels good out there this
afternoon low 90s when that school bell
rings I think you're going to like it it
won't be as windy as it's been sunny and
Mild temperatures right around normal
that will change by the weekend let's
get to the roads though and check the
drive Nate's here with a look trying to
keep that right around normal as you're
getting up and at them checking out that
overall freeway traffic map and the good
news is it is staying green oh it's
jamming up a little bit on the I-15 as
you should expect here around that 6 a.m
hour we have a live picture for you
overhead signs doing a great job of
course no one really pays attention to
the speed limit signs the change up
there these are the southbounders there
are the times of travel from Russell
Road down to Prim just over 40 minutes
for the folks headed for the California
Nevada border North on side doing just
as well got a big heads up for you on
the Las Vegas Strip there's a
construction project there that may slow
you down in fact the Northbound side is
completely closed we'll talk about it
and show it to you in our next report
Heather Nate thank you a suspect and a
double stabbing that forced a lockdown
at Desert Springs Hospitals now in
custody happened around 3 30 yesterday
afternoon Flamingo and Maryland much of
police say both victims are in critical
condition they were stabbed multiple
times the lockdown though at the
hospital has since been lifted our 8
news now investigators have learned a
man accused of stabbing and killing his
own mother last week was released from
prison just six months ago this is 34
year old Pablo benia and he was serving
time for attempted burglary now he's in
custody accused of killing his own mom
74 year old Paula zaniga a police say he
was holding knives a teddy bear and a
picture frame when he surrendered after
a standoff
next week the eighth Judicial Court will
review Clark County's petition to remove
accused murder Rob Tellis as public
administrator on the county filed that
complaint yesterday as Telus remains in
custody on murder charges in the death
of a local journalist Jeff Garman Clark
County spokesperson says telus's annual
salary as a public administrator is just
shy of a hundred twenty thousand dollars
a year
former president Donald Trump is
responding to a growing number of legal
battles the state of New York filed a
suit against the Trump organization
accusing evidence fraud and a federal
appeals court is looking into document
seized from his estate here's Bradley
Blackburn to break down the very latest
on these cases
in a 220-page civil lawsuit New York
State Attorney General Leticia James is
accusing former president Donald Trump
and his three eldest children of over
200 instances of fraud in order to evade
taxes and secure favorable loans the
complaint demonstrates that Donald Trump
falsely inflated his net worth by
billions of dollars
to unjustly enrich himself
and to cheat this system
thereby cheating all of us James said
Trump by inflating his value defrauded
insurers and lenders and violated state
law and potentially federal laws too the
state is Seeking a quarter of a billion
dollars and looking to effectively put
the trumps out of business in New York
the former president last night on Fox
News called the suit a politically
motivated Witch Hunt by James an elected
Democrat well she campaigned on it four
years ago was a vicious campaign and she
just talked about Trump and we're going
to indict him we're going to get him she
knew nothing about me I never heard of
her the former president also addressed
his legal troubles with the federal
appeals court which yesterday ruled in
favor of the justice department allowing
Federal investigators to resume looking
into document seized during the
Mar-A-Lago search the three-judge panel
stated in its opinion that there is no
evidence that the documents were
Declassified if you're the president of
the United States you can declassify
just by saying it's Declassified even by
thinking about it I Declassified
everything Trump also says he didn't
personally pack any of the boxes in
question when leaving the White House
insisting he left that up to the
presidential transition team Bradley
Blackburn CBS News New York
former president Trump's interview was
filmed before the federal appeals court
ruling Trump organization does plan to
follow motion to dismiss the New York
civil suit
it is day three now the U.N General
Assembly yesterday President Biden used
his address to denounce Russia's
invasion of Ukraine he urged other
nations to stand with Ukraine and also
criticize Russian leader Vladimir Putin
and his latest nuclear threats
Russia has shamelessly violated the core
tenants of the United Nations Charter
no more important
than the clear prohibition
against countries taking the territory
of their neighbor by force yesterday
Putin ordered to mobilize 300 000
Reserve troops and in response protests
and a mass Exodus of Russians taking
one-way flights out of that country
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
meantime says his forces will press on
until all of Ukraine is reclaimed
President Biden is pledging nearly three
billion dollars in global food and
security Aid in response to the war
Sherry Nate back here at home at 607 on
your Thursday morning on some health
news you might have access that'll give
you a break in your health care well
later today Governor sisilak will
announce the launch of array RX now it's
a free digital discount card for
prescription drugs and all state
residents can apply for it which could
save you up to 80 percent on your
medications Oregon and Washington have
similar programs now to cannabis
consumption lounges could be opening in
the city of Las Vegas city council
voting 5-1 to go go ahead and allow
businesses to apply for those licenses
of course the county has been working on
the same issue the only place to legally
consume or smoke pot is in your house
these days Las Vegas businesses can
start that Lounge application process
through October 14th Heather the Federal
Reserve announced another jumbo interest
rate hike it'll help curb inflation
rates but it is also causing a dip in
the stock market as you've seen and it
is affecting things like your car loan
your mortgage your credit cards as our
Sasha Loftus reports it is causing
concern about those 401k and retirement
plans as well
it's scary
um sometimes kids have to help their
parents now as the economy continues to
change Cindy Kester says it's been a
real roller coaster recently we've taken
a major hit and we're in very safe
secure Investments she's considering
retirement soon and while she has quite
a bit of money socked away interest rate
hikes and stock market plunges have her
attention inflation is out of this world
right now on Wednesday the Federal
Reserve raised interest rates by another
0.75 percent in another effort to curb
inflation but this is also connected to
a drop on Wall Street with the Dow and S
P 500 Falling by about 500 points a bit
of craziness in the market UNLV
economics professor Stephen Miller says
this has the power to really affect
those ready to cash out their 401K while
also facing a higher cost of living
they're going to be hurt by this not
because of the stock market but rather
because the FED is is going to be
controlling inflation through aggressive
policy so
so time to save
commence kicking things into high gear
now
so you're ready for whatever comes next
so you need to plan for yourself and not
rely on others
social Loftus 8 News Now
Stephen Miller says no matter how close
you are to retirement he does recommend
having a myriad of Investments with
different risk levels he expects the
economic climate to level out by the end
of 2023 certainly hope so coming up
healthy habits for both you and your
child plus today it is Media day at
Golden Knights training camp yes they
are back on the ice one player looking
to turn some heads Sherry all right our
weather always